ん
[音楽]
me
まず皆さんに考えて欲しい事があります
近年の大型台風
大攻勢
オーストラリアの山菓子なんかもまだ記憶
や楽しいかもしれません
高
気温の上昇を肌で感じながら
あふれかえる
次第者がたちを目の当たりにするせない
というのがね嫌な環境問題だけから
イメージと思うんですけど落ちたよね全然
そうなんだけど全然積んだけどってかさん
ですけどでも私はが結局それも環境問題の
一面でしかなくね行って ok ですね
なのでみなさんにはこのペットを通して
ないんe 3ねー
なんか関係問題ってもっとんもっとらもて
たんちがくねとか会えたこんな感じなんだ
はんっみたいなね完全になって頂ければと
思いながら喋りますので10度以下にご
いるで汚いホットキャスト舐めに聞き流し
ていただいてだったら嬉しいなと思ってい
ますハーイちょっと自己紹介食べちゃった
んですけど
今現在女子があった上地学生上智大学生3
年の環境団体グレー造形の設立者兼一県
代表の近所がたのです
私ですよねシンプルに表すと
3つ言えるかと思います
一つ目が
女が待つおかしいぞ
二つ目が感動施肥や水面のがいいそして
最後が大きなはいえ低いです
猥褻目なんですけどこれ
高校生環的に他者とう違う
発音って
松岡沈みてだよね
3つするなと思ったんじゃねぇその後から
自己紹介でいるようにしていますまあ
チョイ掛けないすごい出てきましたです
よし集めろ
感動的なもののようですがこれはなんか
本当に私感情移入がめっちゃということな
んですね
皆さんももうフロー図6という映画のです
ね雪だるまつけそうなネタ
鬼奴はからと思うんですけど私あるの pv
を見てですね
内容一切わからないのにエイム一切みたい
だけどねあの pv だけ見て大号泣し
ました
みたいな人ですねはい三つ目の大きな
アイデンティティーなんでしたが私は
生まれてからね本当に多くの時間を沖縄で
過ごしてきましたもうめちゃ綺麗な自然と
本当に素敵なクセのある人たちと一緒に
行くはさっき意見は今の私を形成するよね
んすっごいたりさんは立てない
街並みなんですけど沖縄でずっとやってた
スポーツはフィギュアスケートです
はいバージョンだとしないですね今日もお
話しする環境問題ってものに関心を持った
きっかけば
私が高校2年生ぐらい的に訪れたネパール
でのスタディトリップでした
なんかその酒がいい今現在もその団体で
理事として働いているんですけど
その時はなんかもね梅の花と葉に行ったん
です
んでしたっけ
ってへ
ハンタん猫見渡す限りの込みでしまー
溢れんばかりのゴミ等が私はジャム外形
だけなんじゃ
いまでもその不幸キャラね結構ビジュアル
的に私はこの長いね結構強いのかと思って
音がちゃんに色番なんですけど中8番目だ
よねファイラーなんですけど私その時1
週間前
スケート練習で人体縁切ってますね
もう本当に変なキーパーシンキって
ください
こんな感じで幸あれいきなりを見てたん
ですね超ネパールずにも見られたし技かん
だでゆっくり歩いただからこそない環境
問題に気付けて今現在もこういう活動が
できている
か船が終わってますねはいはそれ
ネバーれから帰国してきたんですけどまぁ
いつものようにいつも無理なくて箱どうに
かしなくちゃこの状況見たら感じなって
めちゃめちゃ環境問題とかゴミ問題とかに
ついて調べたんですよ
それ
綺麗でしまったんですよね
私が言いたかったとちょっくる環境もない
ってかあると思うんですけど
これは多くの場合に
か肌に問題の原因があるんじゃなくて
私たち先進国いって呼ばれる国に住んで
いる人たちのライフスタイルに大きな原因
があるということに
でこれした時めっちゃショックで例えば
例えば皆さん地球温暖化とか聞くと思うん
ですけど最近はそれで沈みさせていう国が
結構ありますよね
で刈るなどその問題の原因だっていうのは
私たちが李さんとなるとねチェック
ですが今まで輩出してきた結果であって
あるいは私が関心が飛んにもんだこれなん
ですがこの問題の一部は私たち先進国が
まあ仕込輸出と称してね静大のゴミの
プレゼント
保湿ケアを行っているがないんですねえ
でこれ
じゃぁ後小国に入って活動するんじゃなく
て日本を変えらしたと思ったんですよ
で出したら日本かやってるかなぁと思った
ときにじゃあ私が入って大学からでまずは
買えたらいいじゃないかなと思ったんです
ね
つまり上智大です
ここで皆さんに朗報なんですけど朗報
皆さんはどれくらいの人が変われば社会
全体として大きな革命とか変革が起きると
思いますか
答えはですね加害者がなかった恋課題は
3.5%ピースすればいい
って子なんですかたった3.5ジェル
ショッピング中第3で5パーセントなん
ですよすごい絶対これは上手なだけで
置き換えていかないというと
助成額は在校生やクマ14000見るよう
ななのでそれの3.5%
つまり500人ぐらいを変えれば上智を
買われって計算があるんですね
えっ
でいいんじゃないと思いましたれちょうど
手数ですけど私もできんじゃねって思っ
ちゃった私はこのジョージ大学よね500
人を変えるべく
一番てやってないと思えた方法として環境
だんだよ車
車検のグリーンそりゃあは私が1年生だよ
ねぇー
2年半前年前のように立ち上げた団体なん
ですが今現在は上智学生だけで100人
ぐらいが所属する団体の
私たちは上智大学から世界観教員フレイ
さあ
一人一人にできることを3店を2年に
めっちゃいるんですよねで超全力な環境
活動を行っています
康が環境月をする中ですごい大切にして
いることがあって
それは環境活動を全力で楽しむということ
です
なんかめっちゃ美味しいんですけど楽しん
でやってたらみんな集まってくるんですよ
例えば例えば私たちは楽しいからビーチ
クリーンをするし
意識や胴鳴ります超楽しみされちゃう丸ん
ですよ帰れないよねあるけどねとか楽しい
からアップサイクルをするし始めなきゃ
いけないとか
美味しいから b ランたかビジターリア
料理を作ってね
開かれ良いタイムがわかるよまず色もある
よね私が最近作ったり b がちなんです
よ受けるマジだったよまあ私がそれは変な
もの入れたからなんだけどねみたいなレス
でも美味しいもあるんですよ
とかとか
私たちこんな感じでこれをやらなくちゃ
いけないっていうような
義務感っていうよりかはもっとやって倒せ
ているような星達成感というかわずかうお
すごい寿命そして活動をしたりしていた
ってここまでちゃった金18坪ってなん
でしたしてもらってきたと思うんですが誰
か私の活動を頑張るだなあっていうのに
ついてはがしてきたんですが
その後車今自分自身を環境活動部として
認識しています
弊社環境活動家って控えたらどんな人を
想いから
まあいろいろいると思うんですよね選べる
けど例えば写真付に向かって高だーっ
いろいろ工場でも再指定したとかあるいは
すごい優しくてねこの通り抱えたいって
感じで後半そうした人とかも色々あるん
ですけど
だから私は何かそのバックにあまり速い
なっていうかハマるも使う男性は思ってて
ただそもそも私はなっ
恐喝のやってれば飛んだしても回答が
スーッとありませんですね
めちゃ広いでいいって感じなんですけどで
もこれはどんな環境活動でもです例えば
このがないのでもうは一頭も町なイメージ
ですよ環境活動家なんだよ私の好きな環境
活動家で行っちゃうのでここでちょっと
いいよしてきますね
例えば例えば私はマーケットでね二郎を
展開するぐらいが環境ですぞ
地点じゃない環境を別の目指し
後はここに来てあなたもこれ私の大てみて
ない環境問題で完結無理じゃないってやつ
を見てちょっと面白そうでて動いじゃない
をしてきてるわけじゃないですか
動いてみさん活動してるじゃん環境マーク
をかじゃんって思うんですよ稲環境で
ください
あるんですねもう一つ
涼しい環境活動家
結構な引き続きかなって思ってですね
猫連の海外でガスをしているとチキンに
優しくみたいなことってまあ1日にまずで
本当に誤解ができたんですよいるなんです
ね
ででも私なんか
ねほなリエット
地球光に入って
全然大丈夫だと思います
定価やばいれは機構エンドとからやばいで
はむしろ私たち人間だと思っています
なのでもちろんね地球あ
カート物どうか地球のためにやってて偉い
ねってもそうかもしれないんですけど私は
そのように彼は結構せる牛に自分がこう
大切に思ってる人とかこれが大切で追う
大切に思うじゃないかなっていう人たちに
死んでほしくないから活動したりしている
字郷中ますとかです
まあそんなね時空柱でいった者 sma の
環境室
すごい聞こえればそして働いている私が
現在をしているのが本当の意味で
サステイナブルなあかん恐喝
皆さん結構させての前で聞くじゃないです
か再掲
id 3を取れました
自然そうなんですよ
それが今グーグルアースレートに打ち込み
聞いてたんですねそしたら google
先生が
ちきあ持続可能的なたっっ
こんな英語日本語ん意味分からないこと
あると思うすっごい感動したんですね
もはや感動でじゃあねー
それは私どもはトランスレートを入れて
みるといい持続が可能だからずっとできる
ことかなって思ったんですよ
デイどんなことだとずっとできるかな
考えるところ私は私の場合は楽しい音と官
は完成あることとか無理なくできれば
ずっとできるはって事ですね畑山ないけど
ね
でこれってじゃあ環境課となるを得ること
じゃんって思ったんですよ
でそうな私はまあ楽しく無理なく続け
られる環境活動っていうものを考え始め
ました
って言ったんだけどマジちゃうとで
イメージさあでそれ=にめちゃめちゃ閉栓
があってなんか色々めっちゃ心配してき
まで食べていたんですね
私は2はじめ
完璧な環境が5をしようとしたんですよ
者とかね私の下礼を言うんですけど
最近もいたというね私ゴミ問題な半身を
持って環境月を始めたんですよ
で埋め問題あるため2カ月ためにもう
再掲使い捨てプラスチックを使わないゴミ
ゼロライフを始めようって無視だしたわけ
ですね盛大に頭ん中で
すごい雷でやって
はじめも1日目も入れたまま寝ちゃったん
ですよ医師1名
つコンビニはいけないはこんなんですよ
まあこれくらいは良いうで2日目
スーパーも行けなくなったんですよ
でミックえっ
して私悟りました
これフィギュア
売ってっ
今ねどこ行っても酸っぱいとコンビニ行っ
てももう一ガーッと並べられたコーナーに
あーたろすぷらしいたちがいらっしゃい
ませマリーのテンションで書いているじゃ
ないですかまた呼びて
アーチとこれマジ無理ゲーだと思うんです
よ
もちろんでもでもでもだからと言って私の
頃ゴミじゃないけどね希望が絶たれたわけ
じゃないです
まあこれをもってしてこの経験を持ってし
てね私は完璧を目指さない楽しく見れなく
できる環境活動の考えみましたん
でここでちょっと皆さんにも考えてほしい
ことがあるんですね
例えば例えばね
そこに新たあなたが私みたいな感じで
完璧なお店のライフをやってみたと仮定し
ましょう
その時に言っちゃ変わるよねしないでし
たいとかその時にかかるコストを10段階
表してみたいと思いますつまり中が完璧に
ごみゼロなくたね
私はいう環境活動っていうのはこの銃じゃ
なくて
1から9万の環境活動をしようよという
ことです
誰しもね誰しも
ちょっと自由は無理だけど今イラストれ
てると思うんですけどこれは違ってました
これ中は見るけどまぁ頭になった
で亀頭っていうような異変があると思うん
ですよ
そしたら向こうやればいいんですよで後の
後は他の誰してるハッピーすればいいと
思います
か皆でだして銃を目指せばいいじゃないか
なって私は思ってて
でここらへんか面白いことになるん
んだ言って実体1人では解決できない問題
なんですよ
それが醍醐味ではない環境数を持って簡単
ですけど
だからこそみんなでたして中とかない
あるいはみんなで+からこそ中じゃなくて
兄襲名させるかもしれないんですよねー
じゃなくても者豪州とか6人とか目指せ
ちゃうかもしれないんですよね
っていうようなコンディションを保って
いるが環境問題なんですよ面白いですか
あと皆さんこういう視点で完璧にしなくて
いいっていうのを思うことで自分の中で心
の余裕が生まれてね比較的
サステイラードにずっと楽しくできるん
じゃないかなというふうに思っています
あとにもう一つ私環境活動家まぁちょっと
聞こえが悪いんですけど何か自分中間と
仮想化ですねやっていく中ですごいて説明
しているとなって
それはちっちゃなアクションってマジ希望
の塊じゃないってことです
下手だよ超ベタなファンでも何で聞いてみ
たい例えばねさっき
1人が1番版壁に変わるときにかかる
コスト10と仮定しましたね
それに比べて
一人の人がちょっとだけ変われる
まあ例えば丸ごと物が舞いポッ前箱持つと
かアメリカが1するするんですよまあ
そんなにかかるかコスト1とたねーし
ましょう
まあ前者の10人くらいで後者の一番
もちろんが10分の1ですね負担
でも社会に関わる可能性はどうでしょうか
例えばねー
1人完璧な子店の人間が出来上がった
ところで社会が
実になが全部変わる可能性も私はとか低い
んじゃないかなって思ったんですね
でも
1変わる人が10人いたんですか
なんか以前他の負担やベルトはなんか中
一緒ですよね
別名た違うかもしれない
でも社会に関わる可能性として例えば
ちょっとの関心でもたくさんの人が持つ
ことによってもしかしたらスーパーに
プラスチックレス前てない野菜たちが
増えるかもしれないけど
あるいはねみんながうまいことを持つから
9隻が松山に増えるかもしれませんよねー
もしくはねみんな女ってほんとが変わる
なって自動アメリアマレーを持ってきた
から
自動販売機の大きなデザインシートが多く
い起きちゃうかもしれないんですよ
ここら感じでどんなに小さな会社でもない
たくさんある人が関心を持つことで企業が
ねそれをビジネスチャンプあって思うし
まあそれによっているもあった新しいのが
作られてそしてまあそれを見たい人たちが
本当かこんな感じ際になったような後ろ
やってて暖かいしますかもしれないんです
よ
この夏で私は
だから小さなアクションっていうのは
大きな波の始まりみたいなんじゃないか
なって思います始めちっちゃいけどこれで
うわーって利確なっているんじゃねーよね
だからチーズもアクションってもマジで
意外と大きな可能性なんかためです
で皆さんもね始めちょっと覚えがいたら
結構絶望的なシナリオの環境下問題を解決
するために素晴らしい環境活動家だって
くださいって言われた女
やって思うと思うんですよ
であのねさっき言ったようなちっちゃな
アクションを知られて行ってみたり
あるいは自分がハマったなんての活動を
はまった分だけ
ぺこりーとやってみたり
やっていく中でもしかしたらもっとハマる
かもしれないドア前にするかもしれないし
全然なんかちょっとなきゃいいかもしれ
ないがそれですよって言っていいしいい
楽しくてて言えばいいですか私は思います
私はが全員がヒーローになる必要は全然
ないと思っています
私はもう村人 a くらいに新聞です
here 感じたあー
ぬーんっに自分を
書庫の結構どうでもいいお話に付き合って
くださって本当にうれしいですありがとう
ございます皆さん今日素敵な伸長して
ください
うぇい